and to the conflict in Sudan now
activists are accusing the Parliamentary
rapid support forces of killing hundreds
of civilians as we mentioned in Western
Darfur let's go straight to our
correspondent Hima Morgan in cartoon
what can you tell us about these reports
well the darfo bar association a group
of lawyers that have been monitoring
human rights violation in the western
region of Darfur has accused the
paramilitary rapid support forces and
their allies in West R4 of committing
more atrocities at this time in the
locality of serba which is about 23
kilometers from Janina the capital of
West Darfur now Janina is where violence
has led to the displacement of hundreds
of thousands of people from the massage
tribe towards neighboring Chad there
were reports of human rights violations
and atrocities and of mass Graves by
Human Rights Watch that the rapid
support forces have been accused of and
it's where the International Community
international criminal court has renewed
investigation once again into crimes
against humanity and war crimes in the
western region of Darfur this time the
bar association the darfo bar
association said that more than 200
civilians and army officers in the
locality of serba and
have been killed by the paramilitary
rapid support forces and their Allied
militias they say that this time the
ethnicity that is being targeted is an
ethnicity known as iringa and they say
that these are atrocities that could
result in a civil war should the rapid
support forces continue to Target
civilians based on their ethnicities in
West R4
and take us across the situation overall
in the country where does the fighting
stand
fighting still continues here in the
capital Horton today in the early hours
of a Monday morning there were
airstrikes launched by the Sudanese Army
in the southern part of the capital
targeting positions of the paramilitary
rapid support forces we were able to
hear the antenno planes belonging to the
Sudanese Army flying overhead here in
the city of Underman and we can also
hear the heavy artillery being fired by
the Sudanese Army against supposedians
of the paramilitary rapid support forces
in the northern part of the capital we
also know that many homes have been
destroyed as a result of the fighting
between the rsf and the Sudanese Army
civilians continue to be displaced as a
result of the fighting many of them
saying they don't know when this would
end they have nowhere to go to so
they're trying to Bear out this conflict
until it ends whether it's militarily or
through a peace agreement signed between
the two sides right now there are no
talks ongoing talks in the Saudi city of
Jeddah have been suspended after the
withdrawal of the Sudanese Army
delegation who returned to the uh to the
country for consultations so people here
say they don't know what's going on they
can see the fighting going on it's been
more than 100 days they say that they're
not sure where this is going and they
don't know if this would end militarily
or if there would be an agreement
between the two sides but this is so far
they still stand to lose a lot as the
conflict continues
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much Chiva Morgan